Herr Walter, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin circa 48 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie? Genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 15. Juni 1978.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie?
Herr Doktor, warum diese ganzen Fragen?
Ich habe Schmerzen und Sie fragen mich nicht nach meinen Größen.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Können wir nicht immer kommen, Herr Doktor?
Herr Schäfer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48.
48.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 17.04.1976.
76.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schäfer?
Ich bin 183.
183.
Und wissen Sie, wie viel wegen Sie zur Zeit?
Ich wiege so 90 kg.
90 kg, okay.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Manga?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 5. Juli 1966.
1966, okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 163.
Wie viel wegen Sie zur Zeit?
Ich wiege noch 71 kg zur Zeit.
Okay. Vielen Dank für die Informationen, Frau Manga.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58.
44.
50.
Okay.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 1. Mai 1970 geboren.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1.75 m groß.
Ich wiege ungefähr 85 kg.
Okay.
Was fühlt es sich her?
Warum ich heute komme, heißt ich.
Seit ungefähr ein zweites, ein Wochen.
Ich fühle mich sehr erschöpft, müde.
Und habe gemerkt, dass ich mich nicht mehr erinnert habe.
Und habe gemerkt, dass ich etwas gelb werde.
Erschöpft mich da und?
Dass ich gelb werde, meine Haut sich gelb verferst.
Okay.
Hab Sie das auch früher gehabt, oder das war erster Mal?
Nein, ich habe das auch gar nicht selber bemerkt.
Meine Freundin hat mir gesagt, dass meine Augen gelb werden.
Vielen Dank.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61 Jahre alt.
Am 12. September 1963.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1.64 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
65 kg.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Frau Dr. Hiller.
Ich bin 59.
Am 16. Mai 1966.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1.74 m.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
75 kg.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 75 kg.
Wie viel haben Sie?
1.60 m.
Wie viele haben Sie?
Ich habe immer solche Schmerzen.
Es sind keine normalen Halsschmerzen.
Das drückt auch hier so richtig.
Hier oben in der Brust.
Da tut es mir auch weh.
Ich habe es mir zwar wie gesagt,
aber es ist einfach so,
dass ich gedacht habe,
hast du nicht gut gekaut,
hast wieder mal zu schnell gegessen.
Man kennt,
wenn man so trockenes Brot ist oder so,
dass man sagt,
jetzt hängt mir das irgendwie fest.
Aber inzwischen ist es bei allem,
und vor allen Dingen hier so Oberheit der Brust, so. Da tut es ganz doll.
Okay, wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schuster? Wie alt? Ich bin 54. 54 Jahre.
Am 6.8.1979.
Genau.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schuster?
Ich bin 178.
178.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ja, ich wiege total nur noch 72 kg.
Ich habe irgendwie, ich habe sonst immer 81 gewogen, aber jetzt wiege ich nur noch 72, ja.
Sie haben 8 kg abgenommen.
Ja, ich habe viele abgenommen, ja. Das ist auch eine der Gründe, warum ich hier bin, ja.
Ah, okay, verstehe.
Ja, in welchen Zeitraum haben Sie diese Gewicht abgenommen?
Ach, ich wiege mich ja nicht so oft, also vielleicht in einem halben Jahr oder so.
Okay. Ja.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
50, okay. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 28. Juni 1974.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,65 groß und 70 kg schwer.
Okay, vielen Dank für die Angaben.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
74?
Ja.
Und wann sind Sie geboren?
Oh ja, Sie fragen mich das. Am 21. April.
Ja.
1950.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Schweißig?
Schweißig, bitte.
Ich bin 1,65 groß und wiege 75 kg.
Ja.
Okay, Herr Breitling, wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 59 und werde bei 60 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 30. April 1966.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ich bin 1,89 m und wiege, ja, ich bin 150 kg.
Und der 5.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
62.
Ja.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 4. März 1962.
4. März 1962.
62.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
Ja.
Wie viel wiegen Sie seit Herr Haus Cote?
93 kg.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
61.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 19. Januar 1963.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,86 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
94 kg.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Untersträckigkeiten?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie heißt der Hausarzt von Haus S.C.?
Das ist Herr Dr. Meiser.
Meiser. M-A-Y-S-E-R.
Meiser.